[Müzik]
Merhabalar Doçent Doktor Alper köşede
akü Bilgisayar Mühendisliği başkanlığını
yutuyorum aynı zamanda Sizler bugün
burada olmaktan dolayı oldukça mutluyum
konuşmanızın konusu bilişim
teknolojilerinde inovasyon olacak
birazdan göreceğimiz üzere Ben size daha
çok Yapay Zeka makine öğrenmesi gibi
kavramlarda bugün ki işte geldiği
aşamadan işte hepimizin
çektiği biliyorsunuz vardı Sonradan çok
farklı gündemde ne olduğunu neler
yapıyor neden bahsedeceğim şöyle yavaş
yavaş slaytlarıyla Bu arada Bizler
birazdan sunum olarak Diğer hocalara
göre biraz zayıf kalabiliyoruz yani
erkenden görseller biraz daha
daha aldık elinden geleni yapacağım
sonra bunun akışından bahsetmiştim ben
kısaca öncelikli olarak Yapay Zeka
kavramından biraz bahsedeceğiz
sonrasında yapay zekanın geçmişten ne
durumda olduğu Yani bunlar 5-6 sene
Ondan sonra beni durumda oldu şimdi
nerelere gittiğini göreceğiz Sonrasında
da üretken yapay zekâ var aslında
günümüzde artık çokça duymaya
başlayacaksınız Duymayanlar istedi
onlardan bahsedeceğiz
Öncelikle Park çok birbirine
karıştırılan kavramlar var Örneğin Yapay
Zeka makine öğrenmesi Belki bizim teknik
alan daha gidenler derin öğrenme bunlar
aslında birbirleriyle iç içe geçen
kavramlar bu fikri ben o yüzden koydum
Aslında her hepsini çerçevelerin ardışık
internet
makineleri algoritmalar yer almakta ya
da bunlarla ilgili tanımlar var bir tane
onların hızlıca geçeceğim Bazı yerlerde
sadece söylemek gerekiyor Yani burada
yaparken henüz katmanda yer alan bir
hastanın terminoloji
zaten burada bunları göreceğiz işte
Öncelikle ortada ben yapmıştım problem
çözmek için uygun teknikleri öğrenme ve
uygulamayı tanıyorlar tanımlanıyor zeka
Normalde buradan yola çıkarak işte Yapay
zeka kavramı ortaya çıkıyor zaten Tekrar
ederseniz Yapay Zeka kavramı oldukça
eski 1955 yılında ortaya çıkan bir
kavram donmak karşı tarafından ister
Profesör tarafından ortaya çıkardım
Dolayısıyla Hani yapay derken çok
yerinde gördüm ama Aslında oldukça
etkili 1955 yılında daha kötü bir kavram
devamlı işte makine öğrenmesi var
İnsanların da öğrenme şeklini taklit
etmek için verilerin ve algoritmanın
kullanımına odaklanan bir Yapay Zeka
dalım yani makineyi öğrenmesi Aslında
Tıpkı insanlar gibi öğrenip insanlar
gibi tahminler yapmaya çalışıyor zaten
örnekler tek oynadım bununla
ilgilenenlere sahip arada
şu da çok fazla aslında şu an ilginizi
çekmeyecek olan değeri öğrenmede kavram
var burada bugünkü duyduğumuz
arka planda yatan
terminoloji Burada da ben buraya Sadece
biraz acil anladı da direkt koydum
gördüğümü burada biraz daha teknik
kalıyor
Evet
sonrasında hemen bahsedeceğim Örneğin
bir makineyi öğrenmesi gibi problemlerle
ben kendi adıma 2000 yıllar ve
sonrasında itibariyle uğraşıyorum işte
geçmişte neler bekliyorduk şimdi neler
yapıyorlarabiliyor mesela burada birkaç
örnek vermiştim
böyle bir kısma vesaire işte spam yani
istenmeyen mesaj da ortalamadığı
belirlenebiliyordu daha önce Çünkü bir
Hani binlerce mesaj verdiğimize göre
bunları böyle işte Eskiden videoların
normal mesaj dediğiniz
[Müzik]
veriyorsunuz Bundan sonra ne olacak diye
söylüyorsunuz böyle bir inşaat var
Evet yapay zekâ
[Müzik]
tlar var Örneğin
Peki oyun oynamayı seven çok var mı
içimizde
[Müzik]
2016 yılında Google
'da ortaya çıkartıyor
Bu da yani daha çok makine öğrenmesi ya
da Yapay yapay zeka uygun bir altyapı
Dora'nın bir şekilde Peki bunlar böyle
duruyor ama mesela bu bildiğimiz klasik
işlemci şekli zaten tanıdık gelecektir
bazıları da eğer Kurdeleler varsa ve
buradaki gpu dediğimiz ekran kartı
teknolojisi oyunları hızlandıran Aslında
ve bayağı oldukça şu an pahalı durumda
olan cihazlar Eğer GPS olan bir cihaz
alacaksan Normalde bayağı pahalı oluyor
peki sonra bir diğer faktör işte Google
Bunları tek çekiyor Bu da sadece yapay
zekâ
[Müzik]
Ben de görmedim çünkü genelde Claude
geldi internet okulunda çalışıyor Ee
şimdi mesela Pahalı olan bir şey yani
kaynak olarak bile kullanmaya kalksanız
benim gibi karşımda dolar sattığımda
ödev yapmanız gerekiyor Normalde
Dolayısıyla burada maddiyatta önemli
faktörü bunun yanında bir önceki saatte
gelirsek Yaklaşık 10 yıl veya daha fazla
olabilir ama
videonun Yani kredi kartı biliyorsun nvı
oldukça bilinen bir üretici fpsyoda
karşılaştığımız yönelik bir YouTube
videosu var yaklaşık bir buçuk dakikalık
[Müzik]
Peki bundan sonraki konu ne üretken
Yapay Zeka diye Türkçe'ye çevirdim Ben
cennetin Arçelik
kavramlar Aslında Cep TV ve onu benzer
şeyler teknolojiler üretken yapay zeka
olarak geçiyor çünkü mesela neden
bahsetmiştik daha önce işte Mesela insan
yüzünü verdiğimiz zaman aynı insan denk
gelirse diyorduk ki biz yapay zekân
vermesi Bunu tanıyabiliyor ancak şimdi
artık böyle bir şeyden bahsetmiyoruz Biz
bilmediği bir şey Bir de söylemesinden
bahsediyoruz artık üretken yapay zekanın
kavramı bu oluyor tabi Burada bakarsak
bir tane daha önce istemlere yanıt
olarak Metin resim veya diğer ortamları
birlikte üretebilen bir yatırım Yapay
Zeka sistemini kullanmakta biraz çek
cebinin arkasında mesela buradaki
durumda burada geniş bir model yani
Large model deniyor bu Tabii çok fazla
şey yapabiliyor ama en alta da koydum
günler ve haftalarca mesela basit bir
sisteme gitmek gerekiyor don
anım sürekli girdim
milyarlarca web sayfası kadar dökümanı
kendi içinde barındırıp bir sistem
eğitmeye çalışıyor dolayısıyla çok güçlü
durumdayken hiç duyuyorsunuz Yani bunun
o da onlara sahip olmayan birisi zaten
gerçekleştiremez
şimdi devamına bakarsak Aslında
çoğu çok sorulan bir soru O yüzden
buraya koydum çektiği pil ya da benzeri
bir kavram acaba bütün meslek dalları
ortadan kaldıracak mı artık ya zaten
çektiği video her şeyin cevabı veriyorsa
hiçbir şey yapmaya gerek yok mu Bunlar
çok zor oluyor genelde mesela
yeteneklerden bahsetmek için basit bir
şey koydum mesela bilgisayar
mühendisliğine girerken çok basit
öğretmen şeylerden birisi de bu işte bir
program yaz
programını hangisinin hasar atayım o
konuda bulsun çok basit bir giriş
problemleri Normalde
açıkçift diye bunu ya derseniz ya da
biliyor
program dahi yazabiliyor açıkçası Onu
yapmasını mümkün Ben örnek olarak Türkçe
sordum geri aldım Tamam Normalde
İngilizce sormak daha efektif olabilir
ama Türkçe'de görünmez Adamlar Türkçe
sordum benim cevabını alıp yapıştırdım
buraya
artık sadece Bildiğin cevapları vermiyor
size bilmediği şeyler üretmeye çalışıyor
yani bir artık bilgisayar
bence şu programımı alıyorsunuz O da
yazmaya çalışıyor tabi ne kadar doğru ne
kadar yaklaşık onlar farklı farklı
parlatıyor da bağlı Peki devamlı
gelirsek
acaba bütün metrikleri ortadan
kaldıracak mı
bir sonraki tarifte gelelim
Aslında ben bunun kandıracağını
düşünmüyorum şahsi olarak Ama şöyle bir
durum var mesela
Pro inceledik adı verdi adını veren bir
Şu an da gene konu ortaya çıktı son
dönemler çirkin biri bitti from
doğru sorular sormak ve en doğru cevabı
almak aslında gerçekte Bir de sorunu
cevap veren diğer türden değilse Zaten
size doğru cevabı vermeyebilir veya en
efektif cevap vermeyebilir Yani artık bu
bir işe alan haline geldi yani Ben doğru
soru sorayım bana dedi ki cevap versin
Ama tabii ki bu gene de şey tek başına
çözüm olmayacaktır mutlaka insan faktörü
var ama insanların gitgide yardımcı
olmaya başladı
devamında Evet
insan faktörü En kötü ihtimalle
yönlendirecek veya son karar veriyorlar
geri alacaktır diye düşünüyorum Bu
benimki hastayı çünkü
Peki bundan başka neler var mesela tamam
net çekip de Metin yazıyor bize Metin
döndürüyor işte bazen diyoruz ki Mesela
şüphe özetle 4 özetliyor İşte buradaki
işlemi yapmıyoruz yapıyor ya da 3+2
kaçtır böyle Mesela bize cevabını
veriyor bunları yapabiliriz
Peki Yapay Zeka ya da bu tarz
teknolojiler neler yapılabilir
Mesela bir başka örnek daha koydum o
pınaya engin müft diye bir başka bir
Kütüphanesi ortaya çıktı gördüm
10 farklı enstrüman da 4 dakika müzik
beste'ye üretebilen ve tür olarak
kanunsuzden
tarzları birleştiren öğrenmesi
kullanıyor Yani siz burada gitgide şuna
geliyorsunuz artık yani
besinlerden size Beste yapmasına karar
verdik gittiler Bu sürece dönüşecek bu
yani gitgide Çünkü genişler üretiyor
Yani aslında bu bir örnekti son bir
örneğim daha varsa vereceğim
mesela gene son damlaların popüler
konularına
farklı konu aslında ama
mesela ata binen bir astronotun
fotoğrafı diye bir şey yazıyordu oraya
Aslında bu fotoğrafın elinde yok ama bir
daha atlama fotoğrafı çıkartıyorum ya
gene Olmayan şey üretiyor Aslında belki
at var ama kendi üretiyor
Dolayısıyla üretken Yapay Zeka bu tarafa
doğru gidiyor Yani bütün araştırmalar
buralarda odaklanmış durumda
Bu benim kusurumumun sonuydu
gene soru sormak isteyen olursa diye bir
bölüm açtım teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]
[Müzik]